mark why couldn't they fix the battery
issue I think they don't even know what
was wrong with the battery and I think
that leads us to where we are today an
unprecedented move like you said a major
powerhouse in the smartphone business
discontinuing its flagship smartphone at
a time right in front of the holiday
season or both Google and Apple have new
challengers out to get them what does
that say about the future of the note
like as the note 8 is the known nine
dead now or is there hope for recovery
right it's it's a very interesting topic
because the note brand now has so much
stigma around exploding I think if this
form factor continues this more phablet
sighs phone more akin to the iphone 7
plus the bigger nearly six inch phones I
think they're going to have to rebrand
the entire line if they want to sell new
models of this in the future they're
also going to have to reassure consumers
that future Samsung devices aren't going
to explode it's going to be very
interesting to see how they handle this
over the next six to nine months yeah
absolutely and in terms of what it winds
a meeting for sales let's break it down
to two parts the short-term sales and
the longer term confidence sales in the
short term I think Samsung is going to
be okay they still have a pretty strong
s7 line and other products and their
consumer mobile technology side of the
business but I think longer term as
consumers go ahead and really rate which
phones they want over the course of the
upgrade cycles which are two to three
years every two to three years people I
new smartphone people are really going
to consider Samsung in a new light
they're going to consider these safety
issues and that might point more people
towards a new google pixel phone an
iphone or one of those other smart
phones running android we were speaking
with a mark newman of Stanford Bernstein
earlier on in the day about what it
meant for samsung he is overweight on
the stock and he said look he thinks the
market is permanently pricing out a note
8 pricing out a note 9 no future notes
ever but he thinks that that's actually
somewhat conservative and it's all
basically being priced in is there a
chance that Samsung has the innovation
to get itself out of this faster than
the market thanks absolutely the great
thing for samsung investors is that
Samsung sort of owns the whole pie they
have this electronics components
business and they have this electronics
consumer business so what goes into
these mobile phones like the know and
the sevens are Samsung built components
one of those components is batteries but
another component is display technology
and Samsung has shown that it's far
ahead of the competition in terms of
display components and that really gives
them first dibs at new technology sorts
such as flexible displays more
high-resolution screens things that you
can bend so it'll be really interesting
to see how they improve their display
technology which is really the core of
the smartphone experience so if I able
to do that I don't think we're going to
have too much trouble in the future